[Musica]
vi sentite sicuri in questo luogo
stasera più o meno e quando varcate
quella soglia è uscita nello spazio
urbano riuscite a sentirvi completamente
a vostro agio
proprio come se poste a casa forse
qualcuno di voi sa pensano di sì ma io
sono abbastanza certa che la maggior
parte di voi è particolarmente chi
descrive il luogo in cui abita come una
periferia in fondo in fondo sta pensando
di no e questo in cui viviamo in effetti
un periodo estremamente contraddittorio
perché da una parte il mondo nel suo
complesso si sta organizzando il che
significa che tra tutti i modelli di
aggregazione che l'uomo ha sperimentato
dall'inizio della sua storia fino ad
oggi la città sta stravincendo su tutti
gli altri a mani basse ma al contempo
nel nostro sentire comune abbiamo
cominciato ad attribuire alla città una
caratteristica di ostilità
la città è un luogo ostile all'abitare e
qualche maniera
abbiamo cominciato a ritenere che
l'unico posto in cui possiamo davvero
sentirci a nostro agio sia la nostra
casa
perché accade questo bene quando noi ci
facciamo questa domanda abbiamo la
possibilità di darci alcune prima e
rapide risposte
in effetti a differenza di quando io mi
trovo nel spazio protetto della casa
quando sono nello spazio urbano non ho
privacy quando sono nello spazio urbano
non sono completamente libero media
girarmi di andare attraverso lo spazio
perché la città è piena di confini e
piena di aree in cui io non posso dire
liberamente accedere non tutti possono
liberamente accedere e inoltre non sono
completamente libero di comportarmi
perché la mia libertà si ferma dove
inizia quella dell'altro
inoltre come dicevamo non mi trovo a
essere completamente sicuro può capitare
che io
sente la sensazione di avere la mia
incolumità messa a repentaglio
ma se in effetti ci fermiamo un attimo a
riflettere su cosa vuol dire questa
serie di riflessioni che stiamo facendo
di fatto lo scenario che stiamo
dipingendo e quello piuttosto desolante
di una sensazione per cui l'oms ha steso
tra l'inferno sono gli altri in qualche
maniera per cui ogni volta che ci
troviamo a immaginare uno spazio in cui
possiamo sentirci davvero al nostro agio
l'unica soluzione che ci viene in mente
in fondo è quella di rintanarsi nel
nostro privato
ebbene io stasera sono qui per farvi in
qualche modo cambiare idea almeno spero
di riuscirci
e per farlo vorrei tornare indietro un
attimo a queste tre grandi categorie
valoriali che abbiamo appena elencato
privacy libertà e sicurezza nello spazio
urbano e comincerei proprio con il tema
della sicurezza che così caldo nel
dibattito contemporaneo negli ultimi
tempi ebbene il decisore
l'amministratore all'urbanista quando
deve rispondere a un'istanza di
sicurezza da parte dei cittadini
a disposizione delle strade facili o
delle strade complesse
la prima strada facile la prima
scorciatoia in qualche maniera che il
decisore alla possibilità di
implementare è chiaramente quella di
aumentare il controllo attraverso la
vigilanza e la sorveglianza e come si
può fare tutti voi sicuramente almeno
una volta avrete avuto modo di sentire
nominare l'implementazione delle
telecamere in ambito urbano
un altro modo per implementare il tema
della sorveglianza della vigilanza e
chiaramente implementare l'utilizzo di
forze dell'ordine e ancora un terzo modo
e costruire presi bilico di confinamento
barriere limiti come siamo stato in
questo caso un'immagine che veniva da un
dibattito molto molto fervente nella
città di milano sul tema del terrorismo
e sull'opportunità o meno di usare i new
jersey le barriere autostradali per
evitare l'eventuale possibilità di
ingresso di camion terroristici
all'interno degli spazi
liberi gli spazi vuoti urbani ma se ci
fermiamo un attimo a guardare proprio
come sono fatti questi piccoli
interventi che abbiamo potuto appena
adesso elencare ci rendiamo conto che
nel tentare di arrivare subito a un
effetto di miglioramento della sicurezza
nel cercare una scorciatoia per questo
di fatto o mettono a repentaglio
completamente la nostra privacy che era
il primo degli altri valori che avevamo
individuato come sacri per sentirci a
casa nello spazio urbano o limitano
talmente la nostra libertà da darci a un
certo punto l'impressione di non essere
più davvero in un campo di libertà
democratiche ma piuttosto in un campo di
libertà vigilata in un soft in una sorta
di effetto panottico di tipo carcerario
o infine non fanno che abdicare alla
sensazione e accettarla di essere in un
contesto di guerra
cosa che di fatto non è in questo in
questo stato di guerra rappresentarlo al
massimo grado renderlo visibile al
massimo possibile e non per questo
necessariamente a pacificare lo quindi
guardate il livello di rinuncia che
questo tipo di dispositivi di presidi ci
impongono
quando vengono utilizzati ma almeno
servono a darci con la sicurezza che
siamo davvero cercando il cab e che è la
commissione per l'ambiente costruito
della municipalità di londra nell'ultimo
degli ultimi report si dice e non è
tanto la presenza di crimini nello
spazio urbano ma la paura che quei
crimini avvengano a generare l'effetto
di spopolamento di quello spazio quindi
in fondo se noi implementiamo questo
tipo di scorciatoie che non fanno altro
tutto sommato che rendere evidente la
possibilità che un crimine avvenga non
necessariamente il questo debba poi
avvenire nello spazio se noi usiamo
questo tipo di presidio di fatto
aumentiamo di nessuno la paura è quella
cosa possa venire e forse noi stiamo
addirittura a repentaglio la possibilità
di quella sicurezza che stiamo cercando
non per andare così lontano ma invece
per tornare all'attualità degli ultimi
giorni in italia 3 dicembre 2018
roma pochissimi giorni fa san lorenzo il
quartiere di quella povera ragazza che è
stata uccisa il municipio per allo scopo
insomma di dare l'idea di aumentare la
sicurezza in quel quartiere propone di
the pedonalizzare la piazza centrale del
quartiere stesso
l'unico luogo di aggregazione serale tra
un po la movida giovanile è
l'aggregazione sociale allo scopo
appunto di creare in qualche maniera una
situazione più sicura ma come
allontanare gli esseri umani nello
spazio e farci tornare le auto può
davvero rappresentare una soluzione di
fatto per fortuna questo questo
provvedimento non verrà preso perché la
società civile si è davvero ribellata
questo si deve probabilmente quindi non
passerà per fortuna ma andiamo avanti
il decisore ha ancora la possibilità di
scegliere un'altra strada facile
un'altra scorciatoia a questo problema è
di fatto che di fatto è quella di non
occuparsene di lasciare che qualcun
altro se ne occupi e come si può fare
si può fondamentalmente prendere quel
pezzo di città che non ci serve che non
ci sembra sicura e allenarla dandola di
carta in gestione a qualcun altro
vendendo gliela milano 2018 questo è
l'intervento di riqualificazione di
piazza liberty una piazza nel centro
storico di milano di fatto a cento metri
dal duomo una piazza storica quindi che
quest'anno è stata completamente
trasformata per accogliere il primo
flagship store di apple in italia e come
vedete qui sulla destra quello che è
stato che è stato fatto il lavoro che è
stato attuato su questa piazza è un
gigantesco scavo che
costruisce una discesa che punta
completamente allo store per proprio e
come è fatto questo spazio dal vivo è
fatto così come dicevo in primo luogo
punta completamente lo sguardo verso
verso lo store e crea una condizione
davvero eterotopico in cui non si riesce
mai davvero a capire dov'è che finisce
lo spazio pubblico dove che inizia il
negozio nel col risultato che di fatto
ci si trova in una condizione bizzarri
sì ma in cui non si sa mai quando si
entra in quel sistema normativo tipico
dei negozi di lusso in cui di fatto se
tocco e rompo pago non sai mai quando
comincia cosa sistema di norme non solo
come vedete di fatto per questa
trasformazione avvenuta che trasforma la
piazza in una discesa scalinata verso il
negozio l'unica attività che è rimasta
possibile da fare è rimasto possibile
fare in quello spazio e sedersi e
guardare nella sua lussuosissima cornice
il logo dell'azienda
ma è davvero questo è lo scenario a cui
ci stiamo riferendo davvero pensiamo che
questo tipo di soluzioni facili che di
fatto costruiscono un non costruiscono
alcuna visione complessiva non
costruiscono una strategia ma
frammentano semplicemente la città in
mille la fanno a pezzi di fatto siano lo
scenario che stiamo cercando
io penso che abbiamo bisogno di
soluzioni complesse ai problemi
complessi e naturalmente le soluzioni
complesse non sono mai facili da
raccontare come quelle semplici ma
proverò a darvi un'idea di fatto la
prima cosa da fare è ripartire dalle
periferie che brutta frase sia ripartire
sia periferia sono due parole che non
avrei mai usato ma lo faccio per
comprenderci alla breve e perché
ripartire dalle periferie per salire
sull'onda mediatica che sta coinvolgendo
assolutamente questo contesto agli
ultimi anni o peggio ancora per
cavalcare l'onda politica di allo stesso
tempo sta
provvedendo ad appropriarsi e
cannibalizzare questo tema sempre sempre
di più no piuttosto ripartire dalle
periferie perché le periferie sono
quell'ambito della città quella parte
della città che non avendo valori
consolidati ma dal punto di vista
identitario ma dal punto di vista
storico né dal punto di vista della
qualità dell'abitare da dal punto di
vista di una identità condivisa con la
popolazione non avendo tutto questo
schema di valori alla base sono il campo
in cui il decisore l'urbanista hanno di
fatto le mani molto più libera cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che la periferia e il
campo assoluto della possibilità è il
luogo in cui la trasformazione può
andare più lontano in qualsiasi scenario
nel bene e nel male e quindi è il
momento di prendere parte e di scegliere
una strada
voi da che parte state io credo che
abbiamo bisogno di città ribelli non su
di noi che ci guardino e che permettono
a noi di guardarci l'un l'altro che
l'unico modo per ottenere sicurezza in
quello che si chiama sorveglianza
naturale senza per questo implicare
livelli di aggressività e di angoscia
tecnologica o pseudo belli che io penso
che abbiamo bisogno di città che
giochino con noi a tutti i giochi
possibili tra cui quello divertente e
serissimo della democrazia
io penso che abbiamo bisogno di città
vive che ci curino e che al contempo si
lascino brand in alcune di loro
io penso che abbiamo bisogno di città
che accolgano i nostri corpi
tutti a prescindere da quello che sono
meno capaci di fare io penso che abbiamo
bisogno di città che non impongono un
unico modo per essere usate ma che
lascino a noi
la decisione di come utilizzarle
ebbene tutto questo si chiama diritto
alla città e in urbanistica esiste un
modo per misurarlo per descriverlo
e questo modo è una grandezza una
grandezza che si chiama public e mi
dispiace molto purtroppo dover usare una
parola inglese per descriverla di fatto
public ness è la capacità o la
caratteristica di un luogo di un bene di
essere pubblico e capite bene che
l'italia ma noi non abbiamo più una
parola per dire questo perché la pena
traduzione del termine public ness
che è come capite bene pubblicità è una
parola che non ha più niente a che
vedere con l'aria semantica delle cose
pubbliche al contrario è stata
completamente alienata verso il dominio
per commercio e dire che l'italia è quel
posto che ha partorito la parola piazza
per descrivere i vuoti urbani
dell'aggregazione e del vivere dello
stare insieme
una parola che in tutte le creature
scientifiche del mondo si usa ugualmente
per un per descrivere la stessa cosa
eppure in questo posto non abbiamo più
una parola per descrivere quanto è
pubblico uno spazio pubblico e come si
misura la public ness
ebbene c'è più public cass quando è
migliore lo stato di cura di un luogo
quando quel luogo è più vitale quando
quel luogo più confortevole
quando e trasparente e chiaro il suo
statuto di proprietà quando quel luogo
accessibile a un maggior numero di
persone in assoluto e quando il
controllo su quello spazio e meno e meno
presente
tutto questo descrive la visione di
diritto alla città che vorrei lasciarvi
e stasera e quindi in conclusione per
assurdo io voglio suggerirvi questa
riflessione se volete sentirvi più a
casa
nello spazio urbano uscite di casa
scendete in strada e chiedete domandate
a gran voce più public
[Applauso]
[Musica]